bring us the meal please thank you so
much hey what's going on everybody for
first we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at
ship from burgerito in Park Slope
Brooklyn where I'm joined by a familiar
face harley morenstein is back in the
building
you know Harley is the commander in
chief of Epic Meal Time the best Cooking
Channel in the history of YouTube where
you can catch him in the gang pushing
junk food to crazy sometimes terrifying
new heights and speaking of he has a new
venture epic snack time pizza in a bag
what is that all about
did pizza in a bag it's honestly it's
90% exactly as it sounds it's a
pepperoni jerky and by the way it's
called super snack time the snack round
I can't use Epic Meal Time because a
major corporation already trademarked Oh
Epic Meal Time in the food space I'm
Canadian so that's my first lesson in
America I'm very happy with super snack
time it's available in every single
Walmart it's jerky that tastes very much
like pizza and that's what brings us to
burgerito ground zero for mashups here
in New York City because today we're
playing dr. Frankenstein with some of
America's most iconic fast food menu
items what happens if you put KFC
chicken fingers into a Taco Bell
caserita what happens when you try to
mix a Big Mac with a chick-fil-a
sandwich does it work we'll find out
today I look for me yes but yeah my bad
I'm fired up about this just very
excited first up we have the big filet
it's a cross between the Big Mac from
McDonald's and the spicy chicken
sandwich from chick-fil-a we start with
the hamburger bun add mac sauce lettuce
cheese and a spicy chicken cutlet
another slice of bread more mac sauce
more lettuce more spicy chicken and
finally some pickles in the bun and
Harley I know on Epic Meal Time you guys
once made a hundred-pound Big Mac in
terms of structural integrity why is the
Big Mac such a nice thing to work off of
I just feel like this a well first of
all the middle bread makes it classic so
you could see that and that oh it's Big
Macs
all right does anyone else have this
middle I think this middle bun just
doesn't exist for any of anything else
right only McDonald should have patented
the middle but if they haven't done it
like how accurate you went with the one
slice of cheese me Dad we Donald's is
like a you get the middle bread you get
two patties what you want two slices of
cheese relax you Pig
you know I like that that's funny it's
better than a Big Mac it's kind of gross
but kind of not
mm-hmm you know I like to ignore the
gross part like when I shower what's
your take on chick-fil-a do they have
them in Canada I don't think we have a
chick-fil-a but when I go to LA I'm big
on chick-fil-a I would much prefer a
chick-fil-a to an in-and-out burger as a
Canadian that is you know far remove the
mole scene and the hype and all that
chick-fil-a is an objective voice of
truth in this whole so yes exactly you
know I got no skin in the game chicken
skin maybe Oh a scale from one to ten
what are you giving this mashup you know
like the old daredevil movies mm-hmm
Ben Affleck the old ones they're not
good ones I like those movies I'm
genuinely a very easy person to please
do you like Big Macs guess what you're
gonna like this this chick Mac who's a
nine out of 10 experience for me
damn yeah the Mac flayed to me is a six
and a half out of Wow Wow what did you
think the last Jedi I'm just trying to
play bad cop to your home there has to
be some sort of balance look at these
two guys eating burgers just enjoying
themselves right got some controversy
looks crazy but it is better than I
thought it would be and I thought I'd
only take maybe one bite and I ended up
you know clearing out half the sandwich
but this is like a meal and a half this
is a big patty
shut it too big patty by the way I took
her to prom in high school I miss you
boo
all right next up we have the crispy
chicken tender quesarito brought to you
by the good folks at KFC and Taco Bell
basically we split open a case Cerrito
and shove mac and cheese and extra
crispy chicken tenders inside before
rolling it back up and then before we
take a bite I want you to think about
that hot ones episode when you're
talking about combining the KFC and the
Taco Bell together and if this lives up
to the vision that you had in think
about this you know how there's like a
Taco Bell and a KFC and they're under
the same roof mm-hmm
why can't you ask for a fried chicken
burrito it's actually good as [ __ ]
Luther nine on ten right here with a
nine on ten experience arena I'm right
with you and I would even crank it up to
a nine point three wow I was gonna go
nine point five and I thought you were
gonna think I was an idiot
no gives out nines and nine ups like
nothing but I'm the one being generous
right now you like mac and cheese don't
you I do a mac and cheese burrito is
brilliant I felt like I traveled like
like 40 years through time
and I wasn't sure if those forwards or
backwards I just left this space I'm at
it content without a body I felt like I
was somewhere else a lot somewhere else
feeling some when well this particular
course has a bonus section so let's see
if we can take this out-of-body
experience higher and higher higher
because we're here at burgerito with the
namesake item which is exactly what it
sounds like a burger Rita I was walking
up I'm like I know what's going on here
I know what's going on here this place
is good and it's practical because you
know a burger especially when you have
the cheese the sauce the fries you know
it can be very messy but this very
portable very clean yeah
we're worried this is like hey hey
scumbag you like eating burgers in your
car don't you
well how about this burgerito Harley I'm
talking to me by the way these are put
in the same class during the nines you
know some people will try it and say
it's a ten Pooh some people will say
that it's a 9.2 whoo and some people say
it's a 9.4 but no one's going lower than
nine no not a real person
you know who would go lower than nine oh
the Nazis
right and you don't want to be that D
people no no no I give this a 9.5 love
it alright this time around it's Shake
Shack and Taco Bell we have the double
nacho fries Shack burger we start with a
Martin's potato roll on the bottom then
a Shake Shack burger patty some Taco
Bell nacho fries another burger patty
more nacho fries and then top it off
with lettuce tomato and shack sauce I
know that Shake Shack you can't get it
in Canada but when you come to New York
it's your first stop what do you love so
much about Shake Shack Shake Shack
itself I'm very big on listen I'm from
Canada so I'm not tainted by any
expectations or I have no allegiance to
anyone no it's gonna be a check
better than in and up time to debate for
me not even close
Shake Shack Five Guys burger fie they
all cook a PP on in and out and I'm just
saying this I'm so sorry but that's just
from the bottom of my heart I have a
heart attack I think I don't think that
there's any reason for this to exist it
was a little smoky kind of bland I can't
picture a scenario in which this would
be a good thing
I like Taco Bell right and you lower leg
shake shock I'm a big big believer that
if you like this thing and you like that
thing you like both they'll love this
thing yeah but I mean I love cereal and
I love hot sauce but hot sauce and
cereals don't go well never said the two
meet no this is cereal hot sauce yeah
yeah I think I would make a couple
adjustments I think I would remove all
the taco bell entirely yeah and then I'd
be very happy with it and then we just
have a great burger I'm gonna give this
uh I'm gonna give this to no on ten yeah
no on ten um yeah I'm gonna give this a
warning I don't think this is a hero I
want to punch it I want to just Elmo
drew automatically get you automatically
get for effort for it existing is
automatic one
also coming hot off the burgerito which
really was a good burger and like
Mexican Texan combination already yeah
this is just like his ugly brother
we just had Alec Baldwin this is Stephen
Baldwin right something went wrong yeah
exactly
wrong the last course we have just a
bunch of fast food raw ingredients from
mac and cheese to spicy chicken fillets
chick-fil-a sauce to a big mac to fries
and then some you have to use at least
six menu items to make a Frankenstein
disgusting fast food concoction I'll
make something for you Harley you make
something for me Harley and then we'll
just see that is pretty much guys how
you become best friends with someone in
a short period of time bonding
experiences like this boom best buds I'd
take a bullet for you buddy
yeah well I see what you're doing so
you're going you're going like keeping
the big mac going mac and cheese on it
well I'm gonna go a little different
I'll use the burrito as an exterior shot
of my boys burgerito
cash them out let's go with this bad boy
over here you can't go wrong my boy
Shawn likes his mac and cheese so this
is Shawn's big spicy chicken mac and
cheese disaster burger and I made it
with love especially for you Harley
thank you so much this is the Harley's
big delicious disaster burrito here you
go buddy that was you see did you see
his drool on your camera did you get
that
that was crazy the beef and chicken
combo is great you know today we've been
mixing two spots and it's kind of hit or
miss but on this last one when I bit
through it I felt like I briefly visited
ten different fast food spots let me go
on that journey because I
I was just like what young and I didn't
I didn't analyze it or not but let me go
on that journey I'll be back in a minute
yeah yeah I'll wait for you
I was amazing I almost got into an
accident on my way back
burgerito you guys got some competitions
okay I'll watch out watch out lean
you're trying to make a restaurant we
just buy other people's stuff and squish
it together
all right Harley this was a good
disgusting time I don't think that I'll
be doing it again but I'm happy to have
shared this experience I'll be doing it
every Tuesday on Epic Meal Time that's
my life and then let's bring it on home
Harley making his dreams come true
super snack time pizza in a bag be on
the lookout Harley so proud of you my
man every single Walmart in the USA it
tastes like pizza pepperoni jerky it's
incredible jerky mogul over here I'm
Sean Evans
till next time Internet Carly it was
good seeing you man I missed you man
listen awesome to catch up
[Music]
you
[Music]